from Katie hey Michael I'm dating a
liberal there's your first problem
things started off fine but more and
more he's trying to empower me by
insisting by pick up the check at
restaurants and open doors for him I
don't think it'll work out but I'm also
confused about how to break up with him
since he already encourages me to see
other men in a relationship
any advice would be appreciated Thanks I
can't tell you if that letter is a joke
or as serious that's how crazy our
culture's gotten now I could see that
being a joke you know some conservatives
wrote that in as a joke I could also see
that being an article on Slate and I've
read articles like that on Slate and
I've heard experiences like that from my
female friends who have dated liberals
that's a very bad situation
I guess though we're all focusing on the
guy this liberal guy who has these crazy
ideas of you know you should sleep with
other men and you should you should pick
up the tab but really maybe you're the
one who's got a who's got the craziness
here maybe you're the one who's got the
the mental problems you're the one
dating the guy I think it's a lesson
there for all of us
we conservatives we're the ones going
along with all this craziness we're the
ones not fighting back
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description